What's this?
We're in a city now?
Hello,
hello Ruby, roar, a runner, exotic, glacial, ninja, zino,
ogu.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Pals and Ruby, thank you for the song!
For Pals and Ruby, 46 months, Pals.
Oh my god, and you're here for the special stream too!
A little static, I'm bad, Acer.
ah who else espany him czar seed of the tier three for 28
months thank you everyone and gifting the song gosh everyone
can we get some more bark knights in chat for everyone let's
get some a little claps in chat real quick everyone azer the
prime thank you guys so much oh my god we haven't even
started the stream technically ah hello tier thank you thank
you also the alerts have been muted because we will be
uploading this mod on youtube so it'll be a bit weird if
music kept playing every 10 seconds thank you guys are you
guys excited for tuning stream look at this neat overlay
here do you guys know i live in the city now you do i live
in the city
thank you for the 100 videos thank you thank you everyone
are you okay it's only 6 p.m right okay because i feel like
this is a special stream today so so for once in our lives
we're doing it for the non-degenerates out there the
non-degenerates gonna have some fun today i've never been so
nervous before usually go in being like what am i gonna say
today even i don't what I'm gonna say.
But today, today I have a plan.
I have a fucking plan.
Ina!
The street was non-Nijin.
I just missed it.
Non-Nijin, not me, people.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you for the fucking seven months at tier one.
Thank you, thank you.
Can you get some more bark nights and chat?
Thank you, guys.
What the fuck?
Non-Nijin, I'm out.
This is a union with the DJ and the non-D-Gens.
We are unifying the two sectors.
Today is the day.
Now you're wondering, what's that in the back?
What are those diamonds out there in the back?
Well, don't you guys know, diamonds are a girl's second best
friend.
Number one are the 3090s.
Number one are 3090s.
That goes like, I mean, I'm just feeling off.
Thank you for the three months of three months stream more
bark nights more bark nights in chat more dark bark nights
guys thank you everyone we haven't even started the actual
part of the stream yet guys ah you guys you guys thank you
thank you i really i've been playing this for like one to
two weeks now and getting a 30 90s for the queen i couldn't
put the 30 90s on my overlay you see here on the spotlight
because uh oh yeah and also they're like they put the
spotlight out being like you can rob us i'm like okay sir
i'll be heading to your house in like two or three hours
after the stream's done remember if you want me to rob your
house make sure you have a spotlight shining in the sky to
call for me all right guys i don't know what the fuck that
cat's doing there though Like, go back to your owner, cat.
Oh, gosh.
Are you guys...
Oh, Marshall, within 11 months!
Oh, my God.
All of you.
Thank you, guys, so much.
I really do appreciate more cats.
More, more claps.
Cats, more claps, more class for you guys.
Thank you.
You guys are more bark knights.
More bark knights in chat.
For all the insane support, guys.
We already hit our level 5 height train.
What the hell, guys?
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Alright, I spent my money on a spotlight.
I won't have anything valuable to rob.
It's okay.
You have sentimental value items in there, right?
You have pets, right?
Alright, guys.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Mrs. Johnson?
Oh!
Is it my turn to present?
Uh-huh.
Okay, Mrs. Johnson.
Alright.
I've been called out.
to do my presentation now guys it's okay i have it's okay
guys i have my usb stick flash drive ready to do my
presentation everyone don't worry i'm gonna head over to the
to the to the staff computer right now and plug in my usb
stick flash drive where i store my presentation and my let
me go over there right now
all right i worked very hard on this i even have no cards
ready for you guys i plugged in my usb stick flash drive on
the school computer and i have my flash cards ready and i i
hope i get an a i hope mrs johnson gets me gives me an a
guys i really do
guys no it's only one gigabyte but it's okay all right all
right everyone
all right
I please I work very hard I just want you guys to know I
actually work very hard on this PowerPoint all right here it
is dokeybird by dokeybird on April 16th 2021 twitch.tv slash
dokeybird we are here on a mission to provide a vision I
couldn't find the English version of this but it still it
still means the same thing so all right so hmm guys you guys
must be all wondering who am I who is this girl right here
for those who don't know who I am and this is your first
time on the stream so so my name is actually Doki quotation
maple quotation bird yes first name Doki last name bird but
no no to be to be fair dokey bird is actually my thief name
so you know how like thieves don't put their real names in
there because it's like you know that's how you get caught
so so i'm called my thief name is actually dokey bird but my
real name is maple or is it i mean i don't know i have like
200 passports i think this is my real name after looking
through like 200 of them i think this is the closest one to
my passport name.
It's been a while, guys.
It's, um, it's been a while, so I don't really remember
which one's the real one.
So I assume it's Maple.
Anyway, as you guys were wondering, what, where, when's my
birthday?
What?
You guys aren't born with five different birthdays.
So I have five birthdays.
Please write this down, chat.
Please write this down.
guys please write this down my first birthday is on December
15th my second birthday is on December 20th my third
birthday is on October 3rd to guys this will be on the test
later so please remember this these birthdays my fourth one
is April 16th which is today happy birthday to me and then
my last one is July 4th I still can't believe an entire
country celebrates my birthday isn't that crazy who was born
first me or america obviously me i'm immortal but then
that's not all guys oh there's more there is more what do i
do well if you guys did not listen earlier uh please wake up
but what do i do i am a thief i am here to rob you so uh a
house will be passed down later at the end of the
presentation and you can put how much money you want inside
but I would recommend putting your entire wallet and the
deed to your house so just remember that guys and a con man
ah Kamatsu thank you for the raid you guys you're just in
time just in time we are learning about me um and a hat will
be passed down down the audience so remember to put down all
your prize possessions in the hat uh thank you very much
everyone do you think this entertainment is free no there's
a fucking 80 entrance fee guys uh but don't worry don't
worry i i know you some of you might have forgotten so just
put 80 in the hat plus your entire wallet anyway
i'm also a cat burglar like i say i also break into your
houses and it doesn't matter if you want me and you leave
the door open and unlocked, I'm still gonna break in.
I break several of your windows because that's where the fun
part lies.
Hey, Ruby, thank you so much for the three months, a
terrible one.
Thank you guys, ah, thank you everyone for the subs and the
raid and some follows.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I really do, I have my note cards here, so I'm having a very
good presentation.
I hope Mrs. Johnson gives me an A.
anyway i actually do have one final thing i do one final job
is that i am also if you guys did not realize i am also an
artist because if you're wondering why do you why do you
take money for art can't you just rob people instead well
the thing is i'm giving like a little restriction on how
many times i can rob someone and i have to fall abide by the
terms of services from various banks and museums and we have
an agreement that i can only rob them like once a year so
because of that i have to i have to do an honest living and
do streaming and art uh because you know i spend too much
money on things sometimes and i realize oh i can't rob
anyone anymore because i i stole from everyone already uh to
wait for 2022 to do that um so now i have
suck i have to do honest work for money god damn he's trying
to carry rob this last week no more for the year that's
basically it every time i rob them we sign a contract and be
like remember can't rob us until next year i'm like all
right unfortunately has to fall a loss most of the year
imagine doing honest work
ah pain so it makes jesus name be getting robbed by me it's
essentially like christmas but not for her some poor is
gonna get robbed this time of 31 get it again by january 1
sorry for no swiping unlucky all right so some of you guys
might be wondering who are these little rabbits uh who are
my rabbit sidekicks my rabbit minions And then the white one
is called Bao Bao.
And he's controlled by the white, the right...
The white bows I have on my left head.
And then the black one is called Me Mei.
So where did he come from?
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Where are you going, Kata Nae-Jo?
So these two rabbits, as you guys can see, I stole them.
I stole them from a lab.
I broke into a lab and was...
like there's nothing here but then i saw these cute two cute
little rabbits bow bow and may may i call them by ball maybe
they don't they don't i don't know if they had names before
but it doesn't matter i renamed them so they're now known as
bow bow and may may we don't talk about their past names
they're if you rename something it's yours forever so that's
the rules um how many posters
their robot you know i've never like looked inside them i
don't know if they're robots or aliens or or animatronics or
like possessed dolls i don't know i've never like you know i
don't know ripped apart and see what's inside of them but i
feel like i feel like they have their own their own souls
and personalities who knows who knows i don't know much i
just let them do whatever they want um they sometimes they
tag along do they speak they don't know how to speak.
Sometimes they tag along with me for heist and stuff and on
North Department just asked those are the rules of the
streets so they tag along with me on various heists.
They love to cause destruction and mischiefs maybe more than
me.
I don't know.
Sometimes I come home and I see them with their own bags of
money and some of their own pets.
So I don't know what they're doing.
Sometimes they're on their own little adventures and i just
let them do whatever they want sometimes they tag along with
me and help me break into various places and that's great i
have a good time with them so mao mao mao mao may be in bow
bow nice to meet you guys all right all right what's next
what's next i don't even know oh okay you guys don't know
what i do i play ppu games so we don't talk about the that
screenshot on the far back we don't talk about that game
anymore uh that's dead to me but i used to be a very good
player and now i not now i'm not
now i play mostly apex and i used to be a very good player
there too but now i'm not so now i'm just medium average but
you know sometimes i want to i want to flex a little i want
to flex my past What I used to be able to do now I can't do
it anymore, but that's okay I still have my memories and
That's all that matters now.
I have my memories We did not we did not speak of the O
game.
We do not speak of it Anyway, I also do art when I have to
do an honest living and I can't rob anyone anymore So if you
guys can see on the right I'm actually I do a lot of emotes
for a lot of streamers And those are some of my favorite
ones over the last last year on 2020 and then you see in the
left all right some of the merch that i've made some of the
um merch i've made because i before before uh covid i used
to go to conventions and sell stuff and meet real people
instead of robbing and exchange us goods and services for
monetary value but now i just steal steal monetary value
items because i realize that's easier
look at all these transition oh what's this tomato I have a
hat now I found my hat
um so underneath everyone's skin suit is a tomato and I
found my hat I found my hat guys isn't that sometimes when I
take off my skin suit?
I don't know where my hat is, but I found it.
So, I didn't hear that.
So before does that mean I can jack you with a pitch fork?
Alright.
Oh, what's this?
What's this over here?
Oh, my surgeon mama.
So you guys do not know, my very talented, very talented,
very skilled plastic surgeon mama is Klaya!
Klaya's my surgeon.
Mama.
I paid her lots of money to make me beautiful.
I went under the knife and now here I am.
That's me.
Oh, what's this?
Hey, guys, you know I know Clea.
She is amazing.
Look at her art.
Look at it.
Look at the beautiful art.
Look at all this.
Look at that.
And my favorite.
I bet you your mom isn't as buff as my mom I challenge your
moms to I challenge your mom to a backyard fight
yeah not everyone can say that your moms are buff as fuck
she lifts every day look at her my mom's cooler than your
mom my mom could beat your mom up but yeah i love her i love
clea she made me the smug little bitch i am today i hope you
guys are liking all these transitions i spent i legitimately
spent way too much time on this powerpoint selecting the
best transitions for everyone and putting transitions on
every single thing i feel like i'm back in school already i
like wait my mom works at fan of xbox i've done it without
you being a small little bitch you know first place thank
you i tried very hard and being a small little bitch all
right i honestly i already forgot what's okay oh yes yes
would you guys like to know the design process i had with my
mom so basically
my outfit inspiration i've always been a thief but in the
before four i realized my other outfit was very impractical
for thieving so I was inspired by a very classic Vocaloid
song Phantom Thieves Peter and Jenny it's a very very good
song you guys should check it out and this is the very first
draft that we had together it was between red or or gray I'm
sorry I can't I don't I don't know colors very well I am an
artist by the way so these are this is the very first draft
my outfit and then and then we got to here so as you see
we're trying to side hmm okay you can't see my legs right
now but we're trying to decide accessories here so I had two
versions at first to put your guys were like what are you
put what are you doing with these tiny this tiny little this
tiny little bags here so this is where I put all my like uh
pick pocket pick pocket and lock the third one was like,
Clea, this bag is too tiny.
I can't fit anything in there.
Where did I put the snacks, too?
Where did I put anything in there?
Do I put pennies in this tiny bag?
So then Clea was like, yeah, this ain't it.
What am I going to do?
Put Cheetos in this tiny ass bag, Clea.
so so we were like so in the end we decided uh clayov uh
decided that this is a better option for my lock picking
stuff and my snackies too my snack breaks whenever i need to
get a snack break i go into this pocket and pull out a
cheeto uh it also fits like other stuff too i guess to rob
you better but but what's important are my snackies only for
eating nothing but Cheetos now that's a nice leaky bag all
right and then we're like I would like more accessories
please so clay uh uh I would like some more accessories and
I just would like you to know uh my ear to my my ear right
here is a clip on because I'm afraid of piercings so
everything you see here are clip-ons, because I don't like
needles on my body.
It's a clip-on earring.
So we were trying to figure out, hmm, what's the best...
What are the best alternatives for accessories?
All of you.
Yeah, but the surgery, that's a clip-on too.
I can easily take my face off.
I can unclip my face off, guys.
It's alright.
They're all clip-ons.
So, you can see all the little drafts we had here for the
different types of hair accessories that I had.
The face accessories I have here.
And yeah, we decided to mix and match them.
So, you can see that we mix and match some of the little,
the little, the little, the clover, heart, diamond, spade.
We mixed and matched them.
I was like, I don't think, I think I like, I think why don't
we try, why don't we try a different sort of mix and match?
Bing bada, bing bada boom.
Here we go.
There's my clip-on face.
There it is.
Next place is skin.
Damn.
Are your hair clips clip-ons too?
Yep, they are.
Everything you see on my face is a clip-on.
Because this is my, even my skin is a clip-on.
Because underneath is a tomato.
As we've learned earlier.
You guys got to pay attention or you won't get an A on the
test at the end.
all right anyways guys we're almost at the end of the
presentation why what already how could it be that fast but
guys we can hit the tart we can hit the target if we work
together that was just a mandatory thing i had to put in the
presentation to to appease the teachers all right the
bibliography so so guys are you guys are wondering who did
everything okay i just want you all to know i just want you
all to know um i spent an hour researching how to do an mla
format on twitter handles so uh i don't know if any of you
guys had ptsd on grade marking from teachers but if you mess
up uh citations and format in bibliographies you get a mark
deduction for every wrong citation but I am a good student
Mrs. Johnson Mrs. Johnson I cited right I did the Emily
format so my overlays most of the overlays you see here is
done by bunnies uh she's amazing I go to her for a lot of
like uh overlays Like the animated cities over there in the
back, the eyes blinking.
She did all that.
She did all of that.
And in my starting screen, the starting screen you saw
there, the animation was done by Miflu.
She also did the transition stingers too.
So give her a warm.
My IV videos is coming back.
When a teacher drills you down with MLA format, you never
forget.
My logo.
My doki bird logo was done by senior mu mu and he's actually
a Japanese logo designer too But he speaks English so it was
great Um at first I tried it I just Google translated I
Google translated English to Japanese and I was like Okay,
can you draw me a logo and then he wrote back in English
because I guess he realized My Japanese was my my Google
translated Japanese was very bad
in english and i'm like thank you thank you so much i who
would have thought i didn't even i didn't even tell him i
know english i just like send him what i want like i i was
like are you open for logo commissions and then in japanese
because i just you know i wrote that in english and then
google translated and then copy and paste it to him and he
wrote back in english to me and i he wrote back in english
it was like Yes, I do logo commissions.
And I was like, oh, thank you.
And we can speak in English.
I was like, thank you.
And the music, the jazzy music we had here was done by Now
Nor.
It was crazy.
He did most of the songs.
And like each track he did was finished in a day.
Which is crazy.
He's like so talented.
And I was like, you know what I asked for him?
I was like, I'm like.
want some background music for my character and i want it to
be jazz and then bam three hours later here's our first
draft i'm like what the fuck okay it's time time for what
it's more time we're learning so much about me and then my
other screens uh uh he beyond oh sorry i'm so dumb i know
So Huvion, she has done a lot of my be right backscreens,
which I will show you guys later on when I have to be right
back and get ready for showing guys the expressions and the
animations that I have that Clea, my mom did for me.
Well, she did a ton of be right backscreens for me, a lot of
them, like the Sky one, the Desert one.
A lot of people who watch my streams might recognize them,
but all of them were done by her.
Emotes, the non-Bark Knight Emotes that you see By the way,
if you guys do not recall, I am an emote artist, but I am
not motivated By anything but money, so I don't draw for
myself because I realized, hey, I can't pay myself, so in
the end, I just pay other people to draw for it I pay other
people to do the work for me, because I realized, hey, I
don't want to do anything for myself Oh my god, CB, thank
you for the gift that's up, thank you CB, can we get some
more Bark Nights in chat for CB and Linking for the Linking
for the Prime, thank you, thank you.
More Bark Nights, more Bark Nights in chat, everyone, let me
get some claps in here, we all know the clap, we all know,
my algorithm has learned how to clap properly now, so I'm
gonna do this as much as I can.
I'm gonna clap Alright and so So yeah Hachi did my emotes
The non-bark night ones And then the other emotes that you
see there I did it I just pulled out MMS paint Drew a sword
Or took a picture of my dog Drew eyes on him And it uploaded
I didn't even like upload the original file I asked my I did
it on stream And I asked my chat and was like Can you guys
screenshot my stream for me Of the emote I drew on stream to
send it over and then i'll upload it on on twitch you can
see in the sub badges too i drew that i drew the sub badges
and you can might some of them some of you guys might see
the little crosshair of my of my mouse on the sub badges
because those are just screenshots of the screen
i'm a very productive member of society all right but if
that's not all there's more so so if um if you stick out all
the way to the end we have an outro video and it's the usual
outro video i didn't change it it's not like revamped or
anything but that was done by evil desu and uh he yeah he's
actually amazing he's done like a lot of uh animated videos
with motion graphics and stuff with people like pokemon and
everything and i saw the stuff he's then I'm like, hmm,
here's money that I stole.
Can you do one for me too?
And then yep, he did the outro video.
And the other graphics, Hebe, Hebe, I've gone to her many
numerous times, like YouTube thumbnails, the video
thumbnails that I want, um, that, uh, some YouTube
thumbnails, like any graphics I need, like emergency or just
like something super quick done, I go to Hebe for it.
And she also does the postcards for them.
If you guys, uh, for those of you who know about the she did
most she did not most all the graphics for the postcards you
stole of course I'm a thief I'm just an honest thief trying
to make a living of course I stole and then the alerts if
you guys the alerts these guys have commissioned over the
years so insanity poor and Cassie's have done most of the
alerts that you see here in terms of like follow
subscriptions and what else what else do people do raids
hosts like most of all those bits most of all those alert
animations you see there the artwork for that were done by
those three so yeah it's great all right so that is actually
the end of my powerpoint do i get an a mrs johnson i did the
thing uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh Oh, all right, Mrs. Johnson said
I got a C, but that's
I tried to make that.
It's okay.
You felt successfully.
Hey, guys.
I passed.
Everyone.
I passed, guys.
I got a C.
to be fair it doesn't really matter how well you do in
school seeds get degrees all you have to do is pass jobs
don't care if you if you like barely if you got through
school by a nice solid 70% what is passing a nice solid uh
68% it's all right as long as you get the degree.
Thanks, Mrs. Johnson.
Thank you.
Alright, guys.
Alright, so what's next, you guys are wondering.
What's next?
Because that was a very short, um, that was a very short
PowerPoint.
What are my likes and dislikes?
What are the, what are my favorite games?
What are the music?
I like, we don't need to care about that right now.
What we need to care about is look at all the things I can
do with my body.
Now, I'll be right back real quick while I set that up.
hello everyone all right guys this is it this is what you've
been waiting for what can the full thing all right guys all
right so i have several several amazing expressions that my
surgeon mama has given me on my clip-on face so let me show
you guys uh i'm very sure some of you guys might have seen
them already because um i i sort of uh showed them
throughout the my time streaming with this so streaming from
my clip on body uh so let me show you the first one the
first one is the smug it is a permanent smug face now now
the second one the second expression i'll be showing you
guys um is the cry expression
Where did my money go?
Where did all my money go?
I have to work?
I have to do an honest living for money now?
Any more for this year?
No more robbing equals age!
Oh, no, it was really interesting.
All right, and then the next expression, the next expression
that we have is What's two times eight?
Numbers?
Math in my living room?
So that's my uh fuck math expression now the next one this
one is my favorite too I like I really math is it really
carrot you this is this is one of my this is another one of
my favorite ones that my surgeon mama has given me
I love food I love my little cheetos in my cheeto pocket oh
and also money
my $80 entrance fee to the stream money
thank you everyone for paying the $80 entrance fee guys
thank you let me see what she's got her arm I see Ruby is
gonna redeem one of another favorites I wanna do we have to
pay every time every 10 seconds you gotta pay 80 to keep
watching it's like you know like those like paid paper uh
pay to watch videos every every 10 seconds you gotta pay 80
to redeem the next 10 seconds guys also another uh one my
wallet because this one's a favorite so this is called this
is an animation called a blink animation uh show you guys
when i'm too dumb chalix to do that uh i guess to make me
more dumb i don't i don't that sounds very that seems very
counterproductive but apparently but i guess chalix do what
chalix to do well my love day you're not late you're not
well thank you i mean you missed the presentation where i
got to see you but that's okay all right this last
expression this very last expression that we have is it's
not like I want to rob you or anything baka you
think I really wanted to rob you not really baka
all right so we have two the three three more to go three
more to go but the These ones you guys have all seen before.
You guys, you know what my jokes are?
You only have $2 on me at all times.
You have shoes.
I'm going to take your shoes, Marshall.
Those are some.
Those are...
Alright, so we have two or three more, but I think all you
guys know the last three.
All of you guys know the last three that we have.
But the classic butthart for every follow that you guys give
me.
Have a butthart, guys.
And then the clapping...
The clapping one that I've painfully learned throughout my
years being a manufactured anime girl.
My mama fed me with many, many clapping algorithms, and I
finally learned the right way to clap.
I finally learned it, guys.
I finally learned to clap, guys.
Are you guys proud of me?
The clap immersion.
And finally, the last one, the very last animation I have.
is the dance one and I've shown it I'm dancing I'm dancing
let's put some music on I'm dancing I'm dancing all right
you guys want to see the entire let's look at the the rest
of our body while I dance while I do with a little shimmy so
this is the rest of the body guys guys stop painting in
flamboyance I don't have
I don't know where I don't know where my hands My other hand
are My clip on hand to do that redeem I don't know where it
is But this is the rest of the body So guys do Anyway I can
show you guys a better A close-up of this So So here Here's
my face And then this is mini me Little details here Little
details with gloves My little gloves I gotta have good
gloves to climb buildings and steal your cat and then rename
your cat and now he's my cat and then this is my little
Cheeto bag I'm sorry I mean I mean my little lock picking
bag that is also that also substitute as a as a snacky bag
and then there is my liggies my little boots my little
reinforced is very reinforced for climbing
So that was That was my entire body there Plus my Cheeto bag
Plus the Cheeto bag Alright guys What's next after that?
Well chat Well chat There's actually Some announcements
coming up But before I do my announcements My special
announcements Let me sing you guys a little song I don't
know how well this is going to go out but I hope it's okay
but I need to be right back real quick so I can set it up
for you guys so give me a sec guys as I be right back again
ah hello oh there's my USB my USB 2 1 gigabyte 2.0 flash
drive all right we don't need you anymore I can throw you
away now all right guys let me uh let me put get the let me
get the mic real quick let me get out of my pocket hmm and
let me give myself some some much needed much needed reverb
reverb echo echo yeah it also fits my mic to my little my
snacky bag my my snacky bag actually fits my mic as well.
It's, uh, it's retractable.
It's a retractable mic, you know, like, magicians.
You know how magicians fit those, like, uh, put his rabbits
in their pockets?
That's how they do it.
Rabbits are retractable, too.
Uh, please do not test that out.
Uh, they're only, only magician rabbits can do it.
And I appreciate you guys don't own magician rabbits.
Anyway, guys, hmm.
So, technically, let me turn the music off.
Um, we're going to be doing one song and um but my gosh it
was very hard picking the one song that i wanted to sing for
you guys this was very hard because i wanted to be a good
song that will that will be what i want uh what i want to
share you guys for the announcements so so it was very hard
picking this song and i feel like i'm not going to do very
well uh on this song because there's like this very line and
i might just sing it lower like it might not fit the tune
but that's okay
i might need to sing it lower but that's okay that's as long
as all that matters is that i gotta see that's all that
matters guys all right so this let me just get ready are you
guys ready all right guys i'm singing it lower us a lot
there's no way i'm singing the high note there's no way i
can sing the high note for this are you guys ready all right
let me do one last hydration and then we'll do the song huh
okay oh i'm so nervous i'm so nervous guys i'm really really
nervous Today we'll have our last conversation And drink our
last cup of coffee Someday we might be 80 And think about
the different things we used to say All the memories of you
will just become A ghost of a smile Caught in the wind
Someday It'll be the last day
I won't forget how it feels to be loved To be remembered by
someone as special as you Someday I will of coffee with a
smile so the reason why I chose this specific song let me
turn off the reverb real quick so the very first
announcement that I wanted to show tell you guys I hope the
reverb's off yep the very first announcement that I wanted
to show you guys
I'll be graduating on May 14 but that means I have one month
with you guys left so that I have four weeks with you guys
all of you and that's why I chose the sign it must be a
surprise for all of you
and that was why I was very very very nervous it wasn't
because of the scuff PowerPoint is cuz I had to announce
this for you all so you guys are you guys all you might see
very very let me put the song back on like let's let's have
a jazzy tune to it let's have a jazzy tune to it this is not
a sad event guys I know it's I mean it could it is a sad
event but let's make it a happy one let's Let's make it a
happy one.
What do you mean you're graduating on May 14?
What I mean is that I would be stopping all VTuber
activities after my final stream on May 14.
So May 14 will be my final stream and I will be stopping all
content creations and all streaming activities then.
One, this is the last hiatus.
Will I ever come back?
Who knows?
Mm.
So, what does that mean about Twitch Partner and all of
that?
Because we all know I try to apply Twitch Partner like three
separate times.
Well, I don't think it's fair for me to reapply for Twitch
Partner after this announcement.
Only because I know the extra people are going to watch me
after that.
We'll be like, she's retiring!
She's retiring!
She's leaving!
We gotta watch it!
And I feel like those numbers might not be...
Ah, it won't be...
for me so I won't I will be refuting from applying for
twitch partner after that um so this is what I'm not here
for that I'm not here for twitch partnership I'm here for
you guys this is why I'm streaming an extra month for all of
you too because I want to spend the last the last four weeks
with all of you and end it with style so also this is why it
took me so long because I had to do a real PowerPoint after
the scuffed PowerPoint that took me way longer than I
thought it would.
The scuffed ass PowerPoint that I did took me like two to
three days to do.
But this also took me two to three days to make.
So please, please appreciate the real PowerPoint too.
There's no cool ass transition.
Just a little little alright so the next slide after this so
why are you leaving what happened so do you guys remember
how I say I'm allowed to rob banks and museums once a year
so I fucked up and I robbed a bank twice so I reach you guys
the letter that the bank sent me um dear dear dokeybird
promises very seriously.
On April 16th, 2021, you and your rabbit minions have rabbed
establishment breaking the one heist per year agreement in
our contract.
As per our terms of services, the authorities have been
contacted and will arrive at the current given address
listed in the records you've given us in one month's time.
If you're unsure what to do, please don't hesitate to
contact our support team.
Regards the bank team.
I also censored your phone number so we guys won't call them
and be like release her now
and then you guys must be wondering why did you give them
your address well they let me rob them so i figured this was
a fair deal i figured uh please update your windows and stop
now i barely know what two times eight is do you think i
know how to update my windows guys
So, yeah, I gave them my address because I thought, you
know, like, can you let me rob you?
I might as well give you my address.
And I mean, you could just be like, why don't you move?
With what money?
I already spent all the money I used from robbing the bank
the second time.
Where do I go?
Do you know my rabbit minions are accustomed to a very, very
expensive standard now?
Do you want to?
every single day guys you know that's where all the money
goes that's where all the money is going they have my credit
card i think i'm the minion all along i don't know about you
guys i think i i realized i maybe i'm their minion all along
so so the authorities have given me a one one month one
month's time with you all of you and we're gonna make it a
great all right so now you guys are wondering uh what's
what's in plan what's in store for the next four weeks well
then guys well then so i have closed down the curious cat we
will not be using curious cat anymore from then uh after the
stream and i've opened a marshmallow a marshmallow uh
account so it's uh it's just jokie bird
won't be reading any of the messages because those these are
like you know send them anonymously too so these will be the
messages you can send me uh for me to read on my final
stream which will be in four weeks and it's just marshmallow
dash qa.com slash dokeybird some of you guys must be
wondering um can also get my also that too can also get my
80 back sorry the rabbits already spent it on dairy queen i
don't make the rules
So, um, if you guys are wondering, well, but it's all in
Japanese.
Miss Joki, quotation, maple, quotation, bird.
Well, uh, just use Google Translate.
Let's use Google Translate.
But it's just, it's just, it's the same as Function as
Curious Cat.
There's like a little box there.
It'll be like, ask any question.
And then you can write like, I don't know, like a seven page
essay or whatever.
And then click submit.
And then bam, bada bing bada boom.
go um all right so what else is there well at the end of
this stream i'll be setting up several discord channels so b
movie script i don't know if the algorithm is gonna allow
you to submit the b movie script but the last so the i after
this stream i'll be opening several discord uh channels one
of them will be karaoke suggestions we're gonna have um i
think like one or two karaoke nights in the four weeks and
i'll sing some of the songs that you guys suggest for me so
some of them will be like songs i want to sing some don't be
the songs you guys want me to sing so uh it doesn't
guarantee that i'll sing the songs but uh i'll select some
of them so it'll be like one or two uh days where i'll be
doing karaoke nights for all of you and uh another thing
will be variety so there must be a lot of games you guys
want me to stream before I go before I graduate and I'll be
also be opening a discord server for that as well so you can
drop down any suggestions that you want me to play before I
go in those four weeks um doesn't get like I said doesn't
guarantee that I'll pick them but we'll see we'll see
because we can't do chatting and apex streams all the time
so I'll stream some of the games you guys want me to play
And then the postcards.
April and May postcards will still be in effect.
I actually got the April postcards today.
I received it like an hour before I started stream.
So for those of you who don't know what the postcards are,
every end of the month, the top five gifters, the top five
gifters get a little postcard sent from me with little
goodies inside.
And so I'll still be doing the last two months.
But I will be stopping the last postcard on on May, on May
14th, which is my final stream.
Fly Chen!
Thank you so much for the raid, Fly Chen!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great stream playing Apex!
Thank you, thank you!
So, yeah, I'll show you guys the April postcard design.
I think it's after this slide, so I'll show you guys the
design for April.
And I really love it too, because it's like a celebration
debut postcard.
Subgames!
I will be hosting subgames!
um i don't know it'll be on stream but i do want to spend
the most i can with my community before i go so um i will
also be opening a channel for that for you guys to suggest
some sub game ideas so i guess like apex uh jack box um what
else can we play together
uh i don't know but whatever you guys suggest i'll look into
it because i want to house like Maybe like two to three sub
game nights before maybe one to two to three sub game nights
before I graduate And then movie night because I'll be
leaving in four weeks We usually are gonna have two movie
nights For those of you don't know we have a movie night
tomorrow at 10 p.m.
PST on a Saturday We're gonna be watching Raya the last
dragon But because we have four weeks left together I'll be
hosting a movie night every Saturday to be for the next the
other three weeks but i hope you guys will be excited
because i love watching movies with all of you like on every
saturday saturday slash sunday it was it's always a great
time because i say dumb stuff and you guys enable me shop ah
michael michael michael michael good timing so there's also
another reason why i have to announce this early is because
I promised all of you that I will do merch, but it would be
pretty awkward if I opened merch orders And then like four
weeks later, I'm like, okay, by the way, guys, I'm leaving
And then you all be like, but I bought your merch, you can't
just leave So now I give you guys like, you know, you guys
have some time to like decide if you want to buy merch or
not And that's another reason why I had to announce it
earlier because I didn't want to I didn't want to like you
know like be like make you buy merch and then be like I'm
leaving so this is alright I can like release the merch on
the same day as I announced as I announced my graduation day
so and that's why we also have four weeks at the end of the
very end so after this after May 7th, all these, the items,
the merch for, the items for merch, will never be released
again, so they are technically limited edition.
And yeah, so for the merch, for the merch, I tried very hard
to price them reasonably because I didn't want to make
profit off you guys.
I tried to, like, but I still wanted to, like, make sure I
don't, like, lose too much money in general because like,
shipping's, like, really, really expensive but it's a lot
cheaper than usual merch it's a lot cheaper because i i just
calculated like production cost and like shipping and
because all the items we ship but from me like it's not from
like a separate company that's doing it from for you for you
guys it's i'm shipping it myself and i'm contacting the
manufacturers myself so it was very it was like a lot much
more work trying to calculate prices and everything because
i have to do it all myself and but then but i want to do it
all myself because I want to include a little personal note
to all the orders and and some little personal gifts from me
to you guys for those who would like to purchase the merch
and stuff uh so I know I might lose money in the end because
I I feel like I did price it like like it might be like uh I
might lose money in the end but that's okay that's okay it's
for you guys I did this for you guys and I promise the
promise and I hope you guys The price isn't reasonable
because I spent like, I need you guys to know that I spent
like 10 straight hours just figuring out prices in general.
So please appreciate me.
Appreciate my hard work.
Yeah, shipping again is very weird too.
Like it was very complicated trying to figure out the
shipping and everything.
Especially when you don't have the items to like get the
quotes and everything.
people around be like hey you shipped like dockies before
how much do they weigh
you know i've been stealing money for so long now i think
for the first time in my life i want to get back is this an
epiphany and the final note for the slide is the fan tag um
it is the bark night as this should be, as it should be.
So you can use this tag on Twitter, the hashtag of
BarkNights for like, I guess like fan, like anything you
guys want to like send something, like fan art or whatever.
I'll be looking through the tags at least, I guess every
day.
I'll be looking through the tags every day and retweeting
like anything retweetable.
Can't believe you got to become weak on your old days aren't
you?
Are the rabbits actually siphoning my fucking energy?
My life force?
Who knows?
All right, so I don't remember what the next slide is, but
let's all see together.
Let's all be surprised together.
Chat.
Ah, April's postcard.
So this is April's postcard, everyone.
So like I said earlier, every end of the month, I do a
postcard for the top five subgifters in the community.
and this will be the postcard for April and I usually send
them I actually got this early so I have actually have the
cards right now on me so I'll be shipping them at the end of
the month for the top five sub gifters and they usually
include like little goodies and stuff and a personal, like a
little personal touch to it and everything so yeah and there
will be a May postcard but that'll be a surprise until I get
the finished product it'll be a surprise even for me because
I don't know what it looks like too so so when I get it I'll
show it to you guys don't worry um I am pretty sure I have
one more one more slide left ah the shop the shop so so you
guys are wondering what's in the shop well guys we have the
daki the doki makara the acrylic stand um stickers and
charms so I'll be opening the store opening the store at the
end of the stream but it's just dokeyberry.bigcardle.com um
so let me give you guys a close-up of all of them for all of
you so this is the acrylic stand and i don't remember what
that price twenty dollars so this is a six i was like what
did i price i spent so much time calculating but i don't
even remember how much it cost so this is the acrylic stand
it's double sided and it's the and then i'm doing a butthart
i'm doing look at that i'm doing look at that now there's
three of us there's three of us it's um it's a double-sided
it's a double-sided acrylic stand and with a unique circular
base of the background you guys always see a lot now there's
three of me which one's the real me i don't even know all
right the next the next are the charms are the charms this
is also oh yeah that of course we all know who did the
acrylic style my surgeon mama Clea it was very hard trying
to pick out the base but I realized you know what we all I
feel like the rabbit would be much more memorable though
than the logo so I chose a rabbit in the end because we were
spent like hours trying to fucking decide one tells only
lies one only tells truth the 30s cheetahs all right so the
next item are the are the acrylic charms the acrylic is the
2.5 double-sided acrylic charm what did i price it as ah
eight dollars i had to look i had to look because i don't
remember i had to i we all know i don't remember numbers
whenever i see numbers i go numbers of math Oh shit,
Whadding was Michael all along!
Oh my god!
Alright, so yeah, it is a double-sided acrylic charm, and
it's gonna come with a star collapse.
So it has a default expression and a smug expression.
Also, the reason why this took so long to do is I had to do
all the graphics for these slides, too.
Like all the merch stuff and stuff.
I just do it myself.
So...
Oh!
Okay, pretty cool.
Ew, no, man.
later his smug expression and a default expression for all
of you all right next up the next item are the stickers so
if you guys could see i didn't have uh my friend i didn't
have enough time to finish up the last two sketches but
they'll be done by this week i'm i swear they'll be done by
this week i had so many things to do so it was like so so um
these are three there'll be vinyl stickers um so technically
they're waterproof but i would suggest not testing like you
know like pouring water on it every day to be like is it
really waterproof i was just not doing that but technically
it is waterproof but not as waterproof as you think it is so
please don't pour water on it every day if it rains and then
you got like water on it it'll be fine but like if you like
decide to be like let me let me take these stickers out on a
swim I am not responsible for that.
So the four sticker designs are, and they're $3 a sticker,
and if you want all four of them, it'll be $10.
So the, and they're like the outfits throughout the year.
So all the stickers are, some of the outfits I've worn over
the years streaming.
So the, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
Boba the thief sticker and the hug sticker so I hope you
guys will be excited when the last two stickers are finally
done but I'll be finishing them they'll be finished this
week so so but I hope by the end of Sunday I'll have these
done and then finally the one you've all been waiting for
guys the doki the doki makura so they'll be double-sided to
way a try guy um and they are 150 centimeters x 50
centimeters and they were done by Daphne Daphne Daphne I
have the credit on the site so it's what however you
pronounce it but I'm bad at pronouncing stuff so Daphne
Daphne so and this will be 55 dollars this will be 55 so
anyway uh so those were all the uh those were all the
merchandise that i have and i think the rob the bank one the
bet rob the bank bundle for all of it is like uh 55 the the
daki is 55 but the rob the bank bundle is like 85 i think i
don't know numbers you'll see on the website
And then, if you guys do not know, because I wrote it in the
description, but every purchase will come with a postcard.
So the postcards that you guys, like, you know, like the
monthly postcards I've done, I have some extras.
While supplies last, so every purchase, no matter how small,
like even just by one sticker, I'll send you, I'll send over
a random postcard from the excess ones that I got that have
on me.
And if you buy the bundle, you get all six postcards.
So yeah, so every purchase will come with a postcard, but
the bundle you get all of them Because if you buy like the
singular items, you'll get a You'll get like a You'll get
like a random random postcard But the bundle will give you
all six of them Because we've done like I think we've done
like from December To May So
So yeah So yeah, here are all the prices again for all of
you guys The prices for all of them Grab a big bundle, the
Doki Makara, the 6-inch acrylic stand, the charm, and the
stickers.
So those are all.
Should I just open the store right now?
You know what?
I'm going to turn the store on right now as soon as I
realize where it is.
Where did I put it?
Where is the store?
Where did I put the store?
Which tab is it?
tap which one is it all right the store is launched I've
launched the store woo so it's basically big cart was it
dokeybird.bigcardall.com and I do provide worthwhile
shipping and that's what I'm like most scared about and
thinking like I'm going to totally because I'm pricing this
because I don't really want to earn money like earn like
profit from you guys um so I try to worldwide shipping.
I try to price it as reasonable as I can.
And they're my...
Ah, Yamashite!
Ah, Yamashite, thank you for the $80.
Yamashite, thank you for the entry speed.
This is going straight towards my rabbit, Mimey, and Bao
Bao's Uber Eats bill.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, guys.
so let me give you guys a little reminder I will be so if
you guys are coming in late this goes back the reason why
this is so nerve-wracking is that that was the big reason my
graduation date on May 14 but I am not stopping my
activities as an artist I will keep doing I'll keep doing
artist things I'll keep doing after May 14 I'll still be
doing like art for like other streamers um like doing emotes
and stuff or like graphics and like maybe like work on more
original designs on artwork and and stuff on my other store
um and yeah but i will be stopping all vtubing and streaming
uh streaming stuff after uh after my last stream on may 14
so um and with that said even the discord um i'll keep the
discord server up for a few days but i'm not sure if i'm
gonna give it to my moms or just uh close the server down um
we'll see when we'll figure things out when the time gets
there but my like my other social media stuff every they'll
all be there um it's just that i will be stopping uh the
youtube will be just be an archive i guess
But, uh, every, yeah, but I will be continuing, after May
14, I'll still be doing, like, emo commissions and, like,
art stuff, because Thief's gotta earn an honest living,
because you think I'm gonna let the authorities, you think
I'm gonna let the authorities capture me?
I'm gonna go into hiding.
After May 14, I'll be in hiding, but I'll make sure to post
some art stuff, because I need to fund my rabbits over East
Bill.
so and you pay my rep as Uber Eats bill somehow so I'll
still be taking like art committee you'll still be seeing me
doing like artwork and stuff for other streamers afterwards
because I still need a fun their bill their like eating
habits and stuff they've they're accustomed to a very high
standard of living right now and I don't know how to stop
them please send out
alright guys final let's do some final notes stuff too some
little final notes before we go before we go all right guys
let's do a little i just want to get like up and close and
personal with all you guys a little more zoomed in a little
more zoomed in mike get back in my cheeto pocket mike so
that was the wrong mic i got rid of my actual mic get back
in my cheeto pocket mike
everyone let's the little final notes before um before I end
stream I just want to say thank you guys everyone for coming
to the little this is oh that's why have you guys have you
guys ever wondered why I kept calling it lore stream because
I think it would be weird because I was like I can't call it
a debut stream because I'm announcing my graduation I was
like I can't call it a debut stream I can't call it a
re-debut stream it'll be weird I mean, because I'll be
announcing my graduation.
And then that's why I was like, ha ha, lore stream.
That's why I kept going, ha, lore stream.
Thanks for memories, Doki, like, for the actual real.
Ah, it's okay.
We have four weeks left together, guys.
Save that all, save all that for the last stream.
But, thank you, everyone.
It really does mean a lot.
I know I said this on the last, stream we had but some of
you guys might not know but you guys really did so much for
me um without i got my twitch payout a few days ago and i
was able to i was able to fund my doki doji allergy
treatment and i'm booking an appointment with the vets at
the end of the month and finally i mean he'll still be
allergic i feel so allergic to freaking chicken but maybe
this time he'll have fur
And it really does mean a lot because bed bills are so
expensive and it was because of you guys I was able to
afford treatment for him and it really it really does mean a
lot guys Like I might not be the biggest streamer.
I might not be like super well known, but I love my
community I really love you guys like every day whenever I
stream whenever I decide to go live You guys cheer me up so
much like what like even when I'm like, oh, do I should I
stream?
feeling it i'm not feeling like streaming and i go live and
i'm like ha and you guys cheer me up so much you guys really
do it means a lot everyone it really does like sometimes i
get feel so down and then my and then my friends would be
like you should stream today because it always cheers you up
and it really does i really does are you not gonna stream
anymore after may 4 may 14 will be my final stream i'll be
streaming next four weeks but uh maple 14 will be the final
stream and when I'll be stopping all VTuber activities and
content creation regarding streaming.
But I'll still be an artist.
I still have to make an honest living somehow.
But it really does mean a lot.
But I'll be setting up the servers and stuff on the Discord
server with suggestions on what you guys want to see for the
next four weeks.
And I hope to see you guys tomorrow on Movie Night.
for the for the people that can make it tomorrow on 10 p.m
pst we're gonna be watching raya the last dragon um on
discord so i hope to see you guys we show us the ball spot
before that's a secret that'll be our little secret we'll
see on the final stream we'll see on the final stream so
that would be i guess that would be my goodbye note for for
the stream for today's stream thank you all of you guys for
coming i always i really do appreciate it i really do tomato
redeem will be activated the tomato redeem with rtx on will
be will be redeemable after the stream the next stream will
have tomato redeems so don't worry i will take off my skin
suit for you guys with the hat on i found my hat i found my
hat so i'll put that on too um but yeah i'll see you guys
next stream and make sure to give some input on what you
want to see and what do you want me to sing?
And I'll see you guys next time.
Bye.